At some point in your career, all eyes
are going to be on you. It might be on a
stage in front of 500 people, it might
be in a boardroom in front of just 10,
or it might be in front of five very
important clients. And when that
opportunity arises, if you learn how to
shine, this will completely change the
way they perceive you and your
capabilities. This is where career
advancement [music] lives. And this
moment, it's coming for you, whether or
not you are prepared. My name is Vin,
and over the last 15 years, I've climbed
the mountain that is professional
speaking. Thousands of stages, millions
of people, and today I'm distilling
every framework, every mistake, every
lesson into a complete system. Before
the moment, owning the moment, and then
beyond the moment. You don't need to be
speaking on big stages for these lessons
to apply to you. Stage number one, all
of your fears and anxieties around
public speaking, it's all fixed in the
prep work before the moment. And if you
watch only the first section of this
video and practice it, I guarantee you
it's going to solve 80% of the problems
you experience in that moment. Most
people just wing it when it comes to
presentations, and they wonder why they
get nervous. It's because you're winging
it. Years ago, before I ever began my
career as a keynote speaker, I took
theater classes to help me improve my
stage presence. And there was a rule
that I learned from the world of theater
that blew my mind. For every 1 minute
you spend on stage, you rehearse for 2
hours. [music]
Let that sink in for a second. For every
1 minute, you're rehearsing for 2 hours?
You're probably thinking, Vin, that's
overkill. Yeah, that's exactly what I
thought, too. But then I realized, ah,
this is what it takes to be world-class.
So, it made me think, and I want you to
think about this, too. Most people in
life, they're not going to do the work.
Most people just do the bare minimum.
And I decided, I'm not going to do the
bare minimum as I've been doing up until
that point in my life. What if I started
to do the bare maximum? What if I went
all the way? What if I chose to be
world-class instead of just average and
just being okay? So, I did the crazy. I
learned my speech inside out. I mastered
my vocal delivery, and I perfected every
single beat and every single movement of
my talk, and I dedicated myself to this
for months. And you know what happened?
It paid off. When I delivered that
presentation, I freaking crushed it. All
thanks to the rehearsal that I put in.
And do you know what that unlocked?
Momentum. Every single speech that I did
led to more opportunities, bigger
audiences, bigger and better companies.
Microsoft, American Express, and I've
recently done a gig for one of my
favorite gaming companies, Blizzard.
They sent me one of my favorite
characters, Sylvanas Windrunner, who was
a high elf who then became a banshee of
the undead.
So cool. Now, I know what you're already
thinking. You're thinking to yourself,
"Vin, I just want to get better at
running my weekly team meetings." Look,
you don't have to be extreme like me.
The level of rehearsal you do is
dependent on the stakes of the
presentation. If you've got a 10-minute
weekly standup at work, maybe rehearse
it between one to three times, and that
might be enough. But if you know that
the leaders of your organization are
going to be in that meeting as well,
maybe rehearse it at least 10 times. But
then a 10-minute pitch to a group of
investors that could lead to hundreds
and thousands of dollars of investment
for your business, yeah, I'd be
rehearsing that at least 100 times. So,
let me tell you how to rehearse. I
personally do a seven-step rehearsal
technique as a professional speaker, but
this might be overkill for most people.
So, I recommend at least doing the first
two steps. Step number one, do between
five to 10 table reads. Print out your
script and then read it out loud from
start to finish. Not in your head, out
loud. Here's where most people go wrong
already. They read it quietly while
pacing back and forth, and they've
rehearsed that movement into their
presentation. The way you rehearse is
actually the way you end up presenting.
This is why you see so many people when
they're on stage and they're speaking,
they walk back and forth, back and forth
non-stop. Here's the fix. Read with the
same energy while you're rehearsing in
your room, while you're doing the table
read, with the same energy, same volume,
and same pace as you would as if you're
reading in front of a live audience. And
if that's how you rehearse, that's how
you're going to present and deliver on
the day. Higher levels of energy and
effort during rehearsal leads to higher
levels of retention. You remember things
more when you rehearse like this. And
lower levels of energy and effort during
rehearsal leads to lower levels of
retention. That's why when you read
things in your head, you don't end up
remembering any of it. Just by you doing
step one, that already puts you ahead of
most people. But if you want to take
things to a whole 'nother level, let's
learn step two, which is called improv
rehearsal. What I mean by this is that
you can still have your script in front
of you, but you're going to try to
deliver the speech without looking at
the notes. Inevitably though, at some
point you're going to forget where
you're up to. You're going to forget
what you're going to say next. And when
that happens, don't go to your notes
straight away. Just pause for as long as
you need. Take a big deep breath
and do everything you can to try to
remember. After at least 10 seconds, if
nothing comes, then look at your notes.
The 10 seconds of trying to remember is
the whole point. Because when you strain
yourself to remember, and then the
thought finally arrives, whether from
your own head or from the page when you
check the notes, that struggle is what
burns the material into your mind and
your brain. Another reason why I get you
to pause for 10 seconds while trying to
remember is now you're also rehearsing
in what to do when you forget where you
are. Most people when they forget, they
start to panic, they start to
hyperventilate, they freak out, they
flail their arms, and then they
themselves. The reason I'm getting you
to pause for that extended period of
time while you're remembering is because
now you're practicing a new behavior
when you forget where you're at. Now
instead of panicking in those moments
you just end up pausing, and because
your mind and your body is more relaxed,
you are in a state that's more likely
now to remember where you're up to. If
you think that's enough for you, great.
Take it and use it. But if you want to
be world-class, if you want to do what
most people don't do, and if you want to
be crazy like me, if you want to learn
the seven-step rehearsal process for
your next presentation that has the
opportunity to potentially change the
trajectory of your career, then I
recorded a seven-step rehearsal process
video just for you. Just click the link
that you can see inside the description
below, or you can scan the QR code that
is on screen right now, and it'll take
you to that free training. If you want
to be prepared for the next opportunity
that's coming your way, and I guarantee
you there's an opportunity that's coming
your way, then learn how to rehearse.
Learn how to be prepared. Now, you may
be fully rehearsed, but the moment you
set foot on stage, nervousness and
anxiety kicks in. So, what do you do
about that? In those few moments before
you step on stage and speak, when you
see the faces of all the people you're
about to speak to, and you feel the
attention that's starting to come your
way, all at once your mind starts to
spiral, your heart starts to kick in and
race, you go into overdrive, your
breathing becomes shallow, your palms
start to get shaky and sweaty, and you
think to yourself, "What if I suddenly
go blank? What if I forget my lines?
What if I mess this up in front of
everybody? What will they think of me?"
Even after 15 years of doing this, I
still get nervous before every single
keynote and presentation that I need to
give. It hasn't gone away. But what has
changed is that now I have a system to
manage it, and it works on three levels:
psychological, physiological, emotional.
And you need to hit all three. Firstly,
psychological, and this one is the most
important one. The reason why you get
nervous is because you're only thinking
about yourself. What if I forget? What
if they judge me? What if I look stupid?
It's me, me, me, me, me. It's all about
you, isn't it? And when your attention
is pointed inward, the nerves take over
because all you can see is everything
that could go wrong for you. So, instead
of being self-conscious, learn to become
audience-conscious.
Before I walk on stage now, I always
think to myself, "Even if just one
person in this audience improves their
communication skills, this is going to
create a ripple effect in their life,
their family, their friends, their
workplace, the people they serve. I need
to make sure I stay focused on helping
them unlock their voice so they can
unlock their potential. Today's not
about you, Vin. Today's about all the
faces you can see as you look out into
the audience."
And the second I shift my attention
outward instead of inward, I feel this
massive weight that just falls off my
shoulders because I'm no longer thinking
about me and focused on me. It's about
how can I best serve the people that are
listening to me in front of me right
now. Once your psychology is dialed in,
you then have to focus on calming your
body, your physiology. The reason your
body shakes and your voice trembles in
these moments is because your brain
thinks you're about to wrestle a giant
two-headed dragon, which floods your
system with adrenaline. And then as a
result of that, blood goes to your hands
and your arms and they go to your legs
so you can either now fight or run away.
But in reality, you're just talking to
people. It doesn't have to be that
scary. So, what I like to do before a
big presentation, and I do this every
single time, is before I go out into the
spotlight, when I feel my adrenaline
starting to pump in my body, I dump it
all out. Not by taking a poo. But in all
seriousness, I do get rid of all of
that, the adrenaline, all backstage. And
the way I do it is by doing push-ups, by
doing star jumps, by skipping. And I
know I might look like an idiot while I
do this, but I don't care because the
alternative is walking out on stage with
all of that adrenaline still stuck in my
body. And then the second thing I do is
I do Wim Hof breathing. Make sure you
look it up if you don't know what this
is. And just a few rounds of Wim Hof
breathing will calm my nervous system,
slow down my heart rate, and reset my
mind and body. Now, once I've dialed in
my psychology, once I've dialed in my
physiology, the last thing I do is I
fill my mind [music] and body with good
emotions. And here's something I learned
from one of my friends, Mel Robbins.
She's an incredible human. When I was
growing my speaking career in the US,
she said something to me that I have
never forgotten. "Vin, nerves and
excitement are the exact same physical
state in your body. The only difference
is how your brain reacts to it." And
she's right. Think about this for a
moment. When you're excited, when you're
nervous, it's the same symptoms. Your
heart rate goes up, your palms get
sweaty, your chest gets tight, and your
body can't tell the difference. The only
difference is the label you put on it.
So, relabel it. Instead of saying to
myself, "Vin, why are you so nervous?" I
say to myself, "Ooh, Vin, this is the
feelings of excitement. You're getting
excited." One more trick that I do
before I step out into the spotlight is
I watch funny videos, which puts me in a
playful mood just before I greet the
audience. To recap, shift your focus
outward, burn off the adrenaline, manage
it, reframe the feelings. Do those three
things before every presentation and
watch those nerves start to vanish away.
No. No. No. No. No, Craig. No. No. No.
No. No. Don't make me vanish, Craig. No,
not me vanish. The nerves vanish. Damn
you, Craig. Well, I guess we're just
going to do the rest of the video like
this, then. Well, then let's do it.
Fine. So, now you're in the moment.
You've done the prep. You've got the
nerves under control, and you're about
to open your mouth and say your first
words. This is the critical part of any
speech or presentation.
Craig, can we seriously bring me back
now? This is ridiculous, man.
Oh.
Oh, thank goodness I'm back. If only you
could do that for your dad, Craig. Back
to what I was saying. This is how most
people open a presentation. They get up
in front of the room, they stand behind
a lectern like it's a shield, they sound
overly formal, and then they get
straight into the content. And almost
immediately, you can feel the audience
disconnecting in real time. It doesn't
matter if the content of your
presentation is gold. If you lose them
in the first 30 seconds, you're going to
spend the next 30 minutes trying to
salvage their attention back. And
spoiler alert, most of the time, you
won't be able to get their attention
back. So, here's the rule I live by when
I'm opening my presentations. Start with
connection, [music]
not content. Every single time I do a
keynote, I open with a short personal
story. I don't open with research, I
don't open with statistics, [music] I
open by telling the people a little bit
about me. Specifically, an origin story
that has shaped me. Because storytelling
deepens the connection with the people
around you, and it also humanizes you.
I've been able to now to relate to them,
and as a result of that, they'll be more
invested in what I have to say in my
speech. Because we're now mates. So, by
starting with connection, you now build
a bridge between you and the audience,
which makes the transfer of content back
and forth much easier. And this
principle doesn't just apply to
keynotes. I mean, let me give you an
example with a job interview situation.
Instead of answering the question, "Tell
me a little bit about yourself." with
descriptive words like "integrity,
[music] intelligent, and the classic, my
biggest weakness is that I'm a
perfectionist." Instead, do what I do in
my keynotes. Tell them a short origin
story about yourself. And here's a pro
tip, if you can link that story to the
reason why you applied for the job, if
you want to learn how to do that, click
this video here and check that out.
Because once you do that, oh, this is
going to build connection with the
interviewer right from the get-go. And
to be honest, what is this going to do?
Well, it's going to put the rest of the
interview on easy mode. Why? You already
know the answer, because of connection.
But how do you deliver value now in a
way that keeps people engaged once
you're connected? Well, it's what I call
the 33 33 33 one formula. And I'll tell
you about that formula in just a moment.
But first, let me ask you this. I want
you to think about the most boring
presentation you've ever been to. The
kind that you just sit in and then
scroll through your phone the entire
time. Then I want you to think about the
the other type of presentation. The one
where you forgot you even had a phone.
Where you locked your attention on stage
for a full hour and only felt like 5
minutes.
What was the difference? It wasn't that
the boring one had worse content. The
boring presenter only did one thing.
They just informed you. Whereas the
great presenter, they taught you
something. They made you laugh. And they
made you feel like anything was
possible. When I was building my
professional speaking career, because I
had a background in professional magic,
I went full entertainment mode. And I
used to do 100% magic and loosely link
things into lessons that I'd learned
during entrepreneurship. And although it
was entertaining, I remember hearing the
feedback from the organizer saying, "It
felt like it was just a magic show." So
then I took on that feedback and I was
really butt hurt by that. And then I
went pure education mode. The very next
presentation, all I did was educate the
audience and then I ended up putting
them to sleep. It wasn't until I started
asking every single event organizer that
booked me this single question. I asked
them,
"What do you want your audience to take
away from my presentation?" And then I
started hearing them all say the exact
same thing. "Then we want them to learn
something pragmatic and useful. We want
them to feel inspired. And we want them
to have fun." 33% should be education.
33% should be inspiration. And then the
other 33% should be made up of
entertainment. What does this mean?
Well, it means when I'm writing my
speech, I make sure there's an even
balance between those three ingredients.
I don't go too heavy on the
entertainment. I don't go all rah-rah
inspiration, and I don't go all out
content because it will make the
audience actually
Sorry, I just got a bit of a
>> [sighs]
>> Did I
Did I make you yawn? Cuz if I actually
made you yawn, you have to comment below
and let me let me know because yawns are
ridiculously contagious. So, don't don't
do that to your audiences. Make sure you
include all of the three ingredients.
And did you notice I was still missing
1% for those of you who are good at
math? The last 1% is your X-factor. It's
the thing that makes you unique. And for
me, it was my ability to storytell. It
was my ability to bring audience members
on stage and perform magic. It was my
ability to use my voice, my stage
presence. I learned all of those skills
from performing as a magician. Yours
might be that you know how to make Excel
spreadsheets fun using memes. And this
is the lens that I want you to look
through in everything that you do. I
mean, if you've made it up until this
part of the video, have you realized
that I'm not only here to educate you,
but I'm not here to make you laugh, and
I'm also here to try to inspire you to
be a better communicator. Notice how I'm
using the very ingredients that I just
spoke about. And as a result, this video
is way more engaging, right? Stage
three, beyond the moment. Most people
think the work ends the second you walk
off stage. No. That's actually where
most of the important work begins
because after 15 years of doing this,
I've noticed there are only two ways
people tend to feel when they walk off
the stage or out of a meeting. Either
they're convinced they absolutely killed
it, or they want the ground to swallow
them whole. And in both cases, they're
usually wrong about how it actually
went. I remember early in my career, I
walked off stage for a gig I did for a
group of dentists in Sydney, and I was
convinced that I'd smashed it. The event
organizer shook my hand as I walked off
stage, smiled at me warmly, and said to
me, "Well, that was one of the best
talks I've ever seen." And I was
thinking, "Oh my goodness, really? I
thought I did a terrible job." And that
made me feel amazing. So, I decided to
stay for the rest of the conference.
Mostly so that, you know, other people
could tell me how amazing I was.
But then, that didn't happen. The only
person that said I was amazing was the
event organizer. I remember thinking,
"Well, that's a bit weird." And as I sat
in on the next speaker's session, I
remember sitting there thinking to
myself, "Wow, this speaker is really
monotone. The delivery is flat. There's
ums and ahs everywhere. This is so bad.
I can see the audience checking out and
being on their phones." And I just
thought to myself, "Oh man, sucks to be
that presenter." And then I see him walk
off stage and I see him about to greet
the event organizer. And I'm thinking to
myself, "Oh, this is going to be so
awkward. I wonder what she's going to
say." I see them shake hands and I
literally hear her say, "Oh my god, that
was an amazing presentation. You did a
great job."
>> [sighs]
>> Yep. She said to that guy the exact same
thing she said to me. Which means what?
Which means I was bad just like that guy
was bad. The point I'm trying to make
here is that people are never going to
tell you the real story about how you
communicate. They don't have the heart
to hurt your feelings. And even if they
wanted to help you out, they don't know
what specific [music] feedback to give
you anyway. So, it's easier for them to
say, "Oh, you were amazing. You did
great." So, if the people around you are
never going to tell you what you really
need to hear, you have to find a way to
be able to see it for yourself. That's
what self-awareness is all about. The
way you build it is extremely
straightforward. Even though doing it
takes a bit of courage. You film
yourself every single time, everywhere
where you want to see improvement. Every
keynote, every team meeting, every
pitch, every Zoom call that you can
reasonably get away with recording and
then here comes the painful part. You
sit down and you force yourself to watch
the whole thing back from start to
finish. I warn you right now, you're
going to cringe. You're going to sweat.
You're going to hate the process. You're
going to notice things about the way you
speak and the way you carry yourself
that make you want to fling your laptop
across the room. When I first started
wanting to improve my keynotes, I did
this very thing, but I took it to a
whole 'nother level. I remember duct
taping two GoPro together, one facing me
and one facing the audience and I'd set
them up in front of every single stage
that I was speaking on. That way I could
see my delivery and the audience's
reaction in real time, side by side,
minute by minute. So, when I watched the
footage back, I had both those clips in
front of me. And then I'd obsess over
the footage for days after every gig.
What was I doing when they went to their
phones? What was I doing when they
disengaged? What was I doing well? What
was I doing when when when I completely
lost the audience's attention? What were
those specific things? I started to
learn what no teacher, no coach, no
audience member had ever been able to
teach me. I finally had a mirror, a real
one, a real mirror that I could look
into and eventually it turned into a
whole system I now teach my students and
I call it record and review. And it is
the single biggest reason my speaking
career went where it did. Now look, you
don't need to duct tape two GoPros
together. You don't need a keynote. You
don't need a stage. You just need the
phone that's in your pocket right now.
But here's the catch with record and
review. I wanted the footage of myself
on stage so I could start reviewing it,
building self-awareness of me on stage
so I could start getting better. But
then I fell into this trap. I wasn't
getting any gigs yet. So, then as a
result, I can't record anything so I had
no recordings to review. I wasn't
reviewing anything and then as a result,
I wasn't improving my stage awareness.
And I got stuck in this rut until I
started to come to the conclusion, I
don't need an audience. I can set up my
own stage. So, I built a stage [music]
in my backyard. Yep, this photo you're
looking at right now is literally my
backyard. I got a projector screen, I
got a PA system, I hooked up a
microphone, and I did my first keynote
to my dogs. And during that period of my
life, I was really good at excuses. I
remember thinking to myself, "Damn it, I
need some public speaking experience
where I'm speaking in front of other
humans. I can't keep speaking to my
dogs." Only for me to realize again,
"I'm waiting for someone to come save
me, someone to come give me an
opportunity." And I finally just
decided, "Damn it, Vin, stop waiting for
a door to appear. Build the damn door."
So, I went out into the city, got a
busking permit from my local council,
and I started just talking in the city.
Spoke in front of random people. I
didn't care as they were walking by.
That was me getting a rep in with public
speaking to human beings. Now, there's a
really important lesson here. And if you
didn't quite grasp it, let me make it
really clear.
Don't spend your whole life waiting for
the things you want. Don't spend all
this time learning how to get really
good at excuses as to why you can't
achieve this and why you can't achieve
that. Instead, learn carpentry. Learn
how to build the damn door. Create your
own opportunities in this life. After I
learned how to build the doors of
opportunity, I was now able to walk
through them and build self-awareness. I
was able to build self-awareness in my
backyard speaking to my dogs. I was now
able to go out into public and speak in
the city confidently in front of
strangers. And with this self-awareness
now, I started to get better and better
and better. I started getting booked.
First, for small events, lunch sessions,
and then universities, and then for
conferences with rooms full of 500
people, then 1,000 people, then 2,000
people, then 5,000, then 10,000, and
even more. And I don't just speak on
these stages, I've learned to crush
them. So, that's the complete system.
This moment is coming for you. Sooner or
later in your career, you're going to be
asked to stand up and speak in a room
where people who are going to decide
your future are watching. When that
moment arrives, most people run from it.
They dodge the invitation, they hand
that opportunity to somebody else, and
they spend the next few years of their
life wondering why they never quite got
where they hoped.
Speaking in front of a room is one of
the fastest ways for you to become
visible inside an organization. When you
[music] can educate, inspire, and
entertain the people listening to you,
the leaders above you start seeing you
as the person ready for what's next.
[music] Careers move in those very few
minutes when you're standing in front of
the room and everyone else is sitting
down. So, do the work. [music] If this
video has helped you out, leave a like
and subscribe. It does make a real
difference to how many people YouTube
[music] shows this video to. And if you
want to go deeper on the seven-step
rehearsal technique that I mentioned
earlier in the video, click the link in
the description or scan the QR code
that's on screen right now.